please contact me and we'll i give you
credit
uh
so
my name is ran i'm a data scientist at
the agmax we provide nlp and
recommendation solutions
and today i'm going to talk to you about
a simple solution that might help you
find a more of your client data
so why do i mean by that so here's our
client
they gather a
lot of information from different
companies different sources
and they all pretty much gather the same
information
but
some use different crms some use emails
some use snowflake
all of them have different naming
conventions so
they end up taking the same data and
naming it in a lot of different ways
and that's a problem whenever you try to
to retrieve this data basically you need
to
go to many companies and you need to
join all of these companies together to
one
table
and if you don't know the column that
you're supposed to join on then
[Music]
you can join it and not only is it time
consuming it's actually because your
sample
isn't random anymore it might actually
introduce bias to your future solutions
so our goal is to build a model this
model gets a column and it will predict
the most relevant column to join with
uh also because our customer has many
companies the models should be able to
adjust whenever we get a new company to
join the mix
also one of the key
one of the reasons why they came to us
with the project because it took them a
lot of time to join the data together so
this solution needs to be
in real time
so
our customers have a lot of data but
basically what i'm using is only the
column names
so if you think about it in terms of nlp
column names aren't exactly a sentences
they don't have the internal structure
they don't have the the richness
so what i'm left with is really not a
lot of data to work with
so the first thing i did i took
the logs and whenever i find the join
obviously there's a connection between
the two columns
but what if there's no join it doesn't
mean that there's no information and
they just might didn't know
they can do it
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
take the joints that i do know
and then i'm going to train uh an
embedding space and then i'm going to
use this embedding space to suggest new
columns
so here's an example of the data it's
not actually the client but it's an
example
so we see that we have a client in
customer we said have user id and user
index
date and daytime we know we know it's
the same thing but we also need to make
the model figure out
that it's the same thing
also we have the bucket id that tells us
if they belong together or not and we
also created a depth column that tells
me how many times each column each
column
used to join
so
the overall steps first we need to
pre-process our data and then we need to
figure out the right way to vectorize it
and to measure the distance
and then we can use the nearest neighbor
approach to
to suggest
new columns so let's start with the
pre-process and
[Music]
because we are dealing with a lot of
companies we really needed to take it
easy because you don't want to over
process your data
you might end up with a solution that
works great for the companies in between
seed but doesn't work for the general
companies that will join later
so we took a waterfall approach
first we have these guys
we have a special characters we have a
capital letters so we broke this
and then we have these guys they don't
have capital as though they don't have
special characters any idea how can i
break them
okay no one had a job interview so we
used word break and dynamic programming
so the first step is to build the
vocabulary we use the
american large but
column names aren't exactly a word so
they have a lot of abbreviations and a
lot of
technical terms that we had to add all a
bunch of a bunch of these to the
vocabulary
and next we recursively break the words
and each time we check if the
break part is
part of our vocabulary or not but also
we see
that this process is redundant the
last layer is happening before and the
first layer
happens next but it's basically the same
thing so we also keep in memory
everything that we've done before
this way we
save on running time and in memory
uh next step is spell check
and
for that we use elevation distance uh
basically we take we measure how many
steps we need to take
to move from one word to another so from
the world form to fork
there's one
and from kitten
to sitting we have a tree
so this is about a
spelling mistake but what about the
abbreviation
so we actually needed to
weight the vowels differently because
abbreviation usually drop the valve
next
we had to use the data augmentation
here's another example we can see here
the bucket ids but and we have all the
different columns that were joined
together
we see that it's not very rich and we
have to use some sort of augmentation
so first we use synonyms uh we added
random cinnamon synonyms into our
sentences
next we used abbreviate abbreviations we
took a dictionary of abbreviation and we
also created random ones by dropping the
vowels
next we had to create a misspelled world
for our spell checker
and now we need to vectorize it so the
first step was a tf idf
and it didn't work very well
then we tried uh world to vec
actually at first we used a
already made world to vac a funny thing
the spicy uh
water vector small one doesn't actually
give you a word vector it just gives you
a random
number
so when we fixed it to the big number
for the 300 it worked and then when we
got
more data we were able to train
a vector to a
new world to vac
and also we use the depth feature to add
weights by the importance of the feature
and
in terms of distance metrics so uh why
won't we use the 11 chain distance
uh so basically 11 levitation distance
doesn't capture the semantic relation we
can see here the difference between
kitten and cat is five
and the difference between kitten
kitten and sitting is three
so the semantic doesn't keep
although cats do sit a lot so maybe
that's
something
so we used a constant similarity to
measure the uh the distance between the
embedded vectors
space right
yeah
and then we used uh nearest neighbors
and some would say that's not the
fastest algorithm actually it worked
pretty well for us but
we can always
accelerate it using gpus using rapids
and
next step is to adjust it for new
companies
so we all know
these examples how we can take a word
and then we can use it to uh to perform
vector
operations
so we force the company name into the
sentences and now i can use the company
name as a vector
and i can basically move the solution
from one company to the other company
last step is deployment
so we used skln pipeline and a lot of
our solutions needed to be
adjusted so we used uh a transformer
mixing
but when you go to pickle it it doesn't
save all of it it only save the sklm
model so great so if you want you can
actually
if you walk from the current direction
in the
directory that you saved everything
everything works but as you move nothing
everything breaks
so we ended up moving to cloud pical
that address exactly that
and next we created an api for it and
we closed it in a docker
here we can see some examples
we can see here dtg and we see a
delivery dcg we see a delivery date we
see year and month
we can also see a customer id
a contact id
here we can see
estimated profit so we say we see
estimated margin estimated revenue total
total profit
so in summary this problem seemed
pretty complex at start but then when we
broke it apart we found that it's very
simple and elegant solution
be careful not to over pre-process your
data
whenever you can use dynamic programming
instead of a recursion
and use pixel picker cloud instead of
pickle
thank you
any questions
oh so it's it's exactly
it's exactly the vector thing because
you have
way right right here you have different
blobs for different companies so
the world will shift it
okay
thank you
[Applause]
you